[Musique]
chevrier l'histoire de ce château
commence au moyen-âge ce n'est alors
qu'une forteresse au milieu des bois la
présence de nombreux chevreuil donne son
nom au domaine
chanvrier vient du latin campus caprari
us le champ du chevrier
cette phase art c'est d'abord une façade
renaissance vous voyez les typiques
fenêtres à meneaux à l'arrière elle a
été construite par les dai ont su quand
il achète le château au 16e il préfère
refaire un châteauneuf et puis à l'avant
ce que vous voyez c'est un château 18e
parce que c'est en 1728 que mon ancêtre
jean baptiste pierre henri de la rue du
camp futur baron de chant chevrier
achète le château
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que depuis trois siècles le
château appartient à la même famille
elle l'a toujours habité entretenu et
meublée avec soin une dizaine de pièces
visite elles sont richement décorées de
la salle des portraits au salon de
musique en passant par la chambre royale
lui au 11 et l'huître elles ont séjourné
plusieurs fois au château
on peut admirer une remarquable
collection de tapisseries toutes faites
sur mesure
c'est une tapisserie de la suite des
amours des dieux cette suite elle date
de la première moitié du xviie et à les
considérer comme unique au monde
pourquoi parce que vous voyez son état
de conservation dans des couleurs qui
sont remarquablement conservés vous
voyez les rouges les bleus la qualité du
dessin est aujourd'hui les experts
disent qu'il n'y a que la reine
d'angleterre qui a une collection
comparables
classé monument historique le château
est ouvert au public depuis 1995 une
façon pour les propriétaires de partager
l'histoire de ce lieu est de montrer
comment vivaient leur aïeul
alors ici on est dans une des lingeries
des châteaux mais surtout ce que vous
voyez là c'est la pharmacie du château
où sont conservés les médicaments pour
l'essentiel qui date de la première
guerre mondiale à la première guerre
mondiale et bien mes arrière grands
parents ont financé un hôpital
secondaire de convalescence qui avaient
des poilus partout ma grand mère ses
soeurs et leur mère soignait des poilus
avec des lits installés dans toutes les
pièces
ce jour-là à chevry y est c'est
l'événement l'ornementation de la grille
d'honneur reprend sa place après dix
mois de restauration
elle est entièrement faite avec la
technique d'époque dire qu'on a
utilisées vraiment les techniques de
formage et d'assemblage qui était
utilisée au xviiie siècle pour réaliser
cet ouvrage on a conservé au maximum l
existant c'est à dire que tous les faire
les ornements qui était encore
utilisables
on les a conservées la grille d'honneur
elle et vire remplacer le pont levis qui
a été détruit à la révolution
on est ravi de l'avoir à nouveau coiffer
elle nous paraissait un petit peu
déshabiller et l'a à nouveau
il y à l'emblème de la famille qui
l'habite depuis 300 ans avec notre
blason
le château et son vaste parc l anglaise
accueille le visiteur de mi juin à fin
septembre les groupes i o tac c'est
toute l'année sur rendez vous
chevrier et des décors authentiques
est ce qu'on doit ressentir je l'espère
c'est vraiment une partie de notre âme
c'est notre mémoire personnelle la
mémoire familiale que les gens partagent
pas simplement la grande histoire et
tous les grands événements de la famille
se sont passées là c'est cette âme que
les gens doivent ressentir
[Musique]